hi Milo what's up Keisha um your
Instagram is popping sighs no what is
going on popping as in like really cool
oh thank you oh thank you I was like I
think I haven't done anything since last
spring
no the aesthetic is really like
masculine it's cool thanks like your
photographer or something he or
something ya know or something um it's
funny I don't put a whole lot of thought
into it really I just kind of see things
in life and I kind of take photos have
taken photos since I was a kid yeah so I
kind of look at Instagram is like oh
well maybe I'll post maybe I won't we'll
see what happens well it's just kind of
all through you know my phone's lens
very cool um so second act
I know that j.lo said she only saw you
playing this role yes kind of this kind
of an ego booster isn't it is it is at
the same time though like I'd met
Jennifer before and we both had our
shows on NBC so we crossed paths and
introduced one another and everything
and I'd always been such a huge fan of
hers across the board I mean you know
her music career and her acting career
and what she does out in the world like
you know the betterment of the world
I really just been a fan of hers for so
long that when she said she wanted me
for this romantic role I was like well
yeah of course because I'm a fan of hers
yes and second act is such a fun movie
such an endearing movie was there a
moment while shooting that you loved in
particular or that was just hilarious
you know I kept
because Jennifer's character Maya's
going through a lot of change right you
know she is who she is when she's
working at the the large store then she
is who she is when she's a little more
polished at the bigger firm you know I
only saw the side of her mostly this
other side of her when you know early in
the film yeah she had this lipstick that
made her lips Orange and of course
playing a romantic interest with her by
the end of the scene I would be wearing
said orange lipstick and so I remember
one time she'd always bought you know we
bought the new who takes you no no no
baby we gotta get that off you're gonna
get that off you and she take it off and
I look and like I was eating bag of
Cheetos and so from that point forward I
saw a corner Cheetos and they would kind
of get her a chuckling a laugh and
everything was kind of dive in but yeah
you know that she's such an amazing
talent and performer but also more
importantly she's such a good person
yeah such a great human being so loving
and like deep deeply soulful I don't
really wants the experience of those
that are around her to be positive and
good and you know demands the hard work
but it's it's such a joy to be around
well I love that your character Jack and
this is us where do you see him fitting
into the storylines in the future the
storylines of second-act
Jack have a second I'm no expert act is
kind of like the war is over like what's
gonna wow I mean if we really examine
Jack we've only seen I don't know 40 45
hours of this man's existence and you
know kind of told across different
periods of his life but even though
we've you know seen him with young kids
are seeing with teenagers we've seen him
be heroic we've seen him you know lose
things in war I still feel like who he
is as a character there's always going
to be something to understand from
as a father as a husband as an
individual so where the character goes
beyond what we've already seen of him
three seasons in I think that's still
just where we've only seen one one one
one mountain to an entire range of what
this man has lived
you